snl cast members signals they're unhappy
about elon musk hosting he's not the
first to cause a steer this a cnn
business in a surprise move over the
weekend saturday night live announced
that business mogul elon musk will be
hosting the nbc variety show on may 8
some snl cast members didn't seem too
excited about it in an instagram story
cast member
bowen yank wrote what the f does this
even mean as a caption to musk tweet
from over the weekend
which read let's find out just how live
saturday night live
really is this isn't the first time the
show has steered up the conversation
over its host choices the biggest
controversy regarding the host came in
2015 when that's on announced that
that donald trump would be on the show
the news came out
while trump was running for president
after he made remarks saying that many
mexican immigrants were criminals and
rapists hispanic groups
asked the show to revoke the invite and
a latino group even offered five
thousand dollar bounty to anyone in the
audience
willing to disrupt the show so why are
they unhappy about elon musk
going on snl what's the big deal i don't
maybe they don't think he's entertaining
i don't know you think it is look i
don't know why bow and yang and i
actually i i think he's a pretty funny
guy well look
i think one thing's that's going to be
undeniable when trump came on and elon
musk came on
where am i going with this pat ratings
you know people are gonna be tuning in
i couldn't and i'm a huge fan of snl i
used to do stand-up comedy i'm a
i love i used to be that 13 year old kid
glued to my t
uh tv chris farley adam sandler david
spade rob schneider
nor mcdonald i was raised on that kind
of stuff so i still
you know if i'm not going out on a
saturday night these days at south beach
maybe i'll
a lot of times i'll just watch snl you
know on the reruns or whatever but
huge fan of snl but this is
look with elon musk i think this is what
we this is why i think maybe he's more
of a lebron than
jordan with elon comes controversy
right he's controversial he'll tweet
things he's
unabashedly a capitalist he'll say some
[ __ ] he'll 69 a joke
he'll be an eighth grader i actually
think he'll be quite hilarious on snl
but there's some people that obviously
he rubs the wrong way so if you're
do you know who bo and yang is like the
person that doesn't want him do you know
who that is
he's a gay asian occasion that's on the
uh
i'm going to call you coin i don't know
he's pretty good on the show and you
know maybe he's not a fan
of elon musk i don't know but he's
hilarious
and and and you know i don't know the
the backstory there but
i can think of the script i think about
the the doge father
how about this how about this when's the
last time you watched snl
like watched snl uh um eddie murphy
1986. no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no he came back two years ago
i don't i don't watch it but i'm gonna
watch this um
i can't remember can't remember are you
gonna tune in to see
elon musk i will tune in bingo bango now
we gotta
be committed so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you